good morning john so this video could be
very short uh yes
yes i would take a coveted vaccine i
would i would spend 15 hours in a target
for a covert vaccine i would eat a
blenderized happy meal i would wax my
chin i would give up coffee i would walk
around with clif barts on my feet
instead of shoes for a month
i would let ruby rod be my
roommate for a covid vaccine the news
that pfizer moderna astrazeneca and
others have had really promising results
in their phase 3 trials
it's good it's it's like i don't think
people
get how good this news is or maybe we're
just like so overwhelmed with everything
else in the world but it is
it's like the best news of 2020. it was
entirely possible that this first slate
of vaccines and these are the first ones
wouldn't work it was also possible that
no vaccine would work it was also
possible people wouldn't get any lasting
immunity from even
getting the disease which is true for
many other coronaviruses
it looks like we're finally getting
lucky with something that getting the
disease
does confer some lasting immunity and
vaccines that expose our immune systems
to like little broken off bits of the
virus that can't infect you
also confer immunity now there are
things that we still don't know we don't
know whether or how much getting the
vaccine prevents you from spreading the
disease it probably does pretty
substantially considering people are
testing negative but like we don't know
for sure we also don't know how long
these vaccines last and we won't have a
good idea about that for a pretty long
time but i'm very excited by this
it's such good news and i will
immediately line up whenever
i am allowed to to get this vaccine but
i know that there's also a lot of
hesitancy around vaccines
so i want to talk about like the three
main reasons why i want to do this
first if you are concerned about the
politician or politicians who developed
this vaccine
like you don't trust donald trump or you
don't trust your abiding politicians and
political leaders
don't develop vaccines and the rules and
systems we use to test for the safety of
vaccines
did not change at all in the last year
scientists and doctors very specifically
for this reason
chose to change nothing they looked and
they said maybe there are some things we
could do to speed it up but we're not
going to do them because we don't want
people to feel like we're cutting
corners there are things that we worked
hard to speed up but the things that
take
time we let them take the time which is
why it's taken so long so i want to get
a covered vaccine because i know it's
going to be safe and certainly much
safer than getting covered second thing
when we prevent ourselves from getting
coveted we aren't just protecting
ourselves because every time somebody
gets this disease they become a vector
for other people to get this disease so
by wearing masks by distancing how and
when we can but by taking a vaccine when
it's available
we are keeping hospital beds free not
just for people with covet but also for
anybody who is experiencing a medical
problem or emergency and that given my
track record may very well be me if we
only imagine
the direct impacts on ourselves right
now it will result in more death and
suffering and so why would i get a covet
vaccine so that i can live my life again
without having to worry whether i am
going to be the cause of someone else's
suffering and finally we all need to do
what we can
to help frontline healthcare workers
right now they are having a year
unlike any ever before and these are
people who signed up for
jobs to help people all of the times
when i have gone to the hospital either
with a broken bone or for my ulcerative
colitis
these people have done tremendous
kindnesses for me and how we act during
this pandemic is in a very real way
how we give back to them for the
services that they have rendered to us
in the past
and also will render to us in the future
and are giving to all of our neighbors
and fellow humans right now so i want to
take a covert vaccine for them i'm not
gonna get to do it for a little while
i'm not first on the list and i
shouldn't be but as soon as they tell me
i can you best believe i'm gonna be in
that line it's understandable to be wary
of new things
and of big important things like a
vaccine for a deadly pandemic and i have
health care workers and
elderly people and scientists in my life
who can help give me
the perspective that i have i understand
not everybody has that i think i'm lucky
to have the perspective
to feel like this isn't something that's
being done to me it's something that i
want to do
for myself and for other people john
i'll see you on tuesday